[Music] I'll re-
input
The choices that will cause a chemical reaction between these three with Nagi and Barrow
Update the scenery you see from now on I'll lead this
team to the goal
Seriously, even if you send it to Barrow, the destination
will be completely dead
If things continue as they are now, there won't be a chemical reaction with Barrow Then Nagee's passing course
[Applause]
Infinite images of goals will spring to mind Nagi's
moving,
so that I can
compete with my passes Win off-the-ball from him
I'm going to evolve to a level where I can take it here, right? A fast
bus Are you trying to compete with me?
I
made a shooting course with the trap of this
play that's even higher than my image
This
is the chemical reaction between me and him